I essentially don't have a pulse
you can check everywhere you want and
you won't feel a pulse so I'm pretty
much the best-looking zombie you'll ever
see my name is Andrew Jones and I'm a
professional fitness model living with
an artificial heart I always have to
have batteries charging at night when
I'm going to bed I'll plug my phone in
and then I'll plug myself in to the wall
outlet to make sure I have power
overnight in 2012 I was diagnosed with a
cardiomyopathy which affects the hearts
efficiency to pump blood I was
incredibly ill at the time and I was
admitted to the ICU for four months
where they had to implant what's called
an LVAD which stands for left
ventricular assist device and it's
considered an artificial heart it's
taking over the work of my heart for me
these devices the two batteries and the
computer these are what are powering and
controlling the artificial heart to make
sure that it's working efficiently and
working properly
I started feeling strong again when I
was recovering after having the
artificial heart implanted and of course
it didn't all come at once
I took baby steps and I found myself
back in the gym sooner than later and I
got my strength back and once I'm able
to find the right match for a heart
transplant I will no longer need my
artificial heart at first I was upset
about having an artificial heart and
then there was the moment where I
realized that this is my life for now
and either I can dwell and feel sorry
for myself or I can continue doing the
things that I love to do the best way I
can and I haven't stopped I'm proud of
the scars that I have from my surgeries
because scars are beautiful they're a
part of you
they tell your story
and no one can take that away from you